The MemeMe app let's you create
a meme with an image and some text.
Everyone loves a good meme.
And it's easy to get
a laugh from friends.
This is the meme editor view controller.
It let's you select a picture and
edit text at the top and
the bottom of the picture.
The picture can be selected from
the device's photo album or
by using the camera.
When I press on the camera button in the
bottom toolbar, the camera launches and
I can take a new picture
to use in a meme.
When I press on the album button,
I'm brought to the photo library where
I can choose from recent photos.
I like this one of the baby hedgehog.
Whether we're using the camera or
the album, you'll use
Apple's UIImagePickerController
to select your image.
After I've chosen an image,
I return to the Meme Editor.
Notice that because of the shape
of the hedgehog picture,
I'm making my meme in landscape mode.
Here text is entered into a text field.
When the editing is complete we show
the text in an outlined white font.
It's slightly different from
impact to the true meme font, but
it's pretty close, and
available among Iowa stock funds.
When I click inside the bottom text
field, notice how the view slides up so
that the keyboard doesn't
obscure the bottom text field.
Now our meme is ready to go,
so let's share it.
You can find the share button
in the upper left corner.
And here's our old friend,
the activity view controller.
Let's send this to Kunal.
And that's all there is to it.